[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
stop je ne suis pas encore en vacances
malheureusement alors dire les vacances
pour quelqu'un comme moi c'est super
cool ça me permet d'avoir une cassure
avec le véritable cycle du no life à
savoir quelque chose comme ça le cycle
du no life en huit étapes à dormir
saleh vais manger se doucher leaké ans
j'ai cliqué coucher et rebelote et
faites pas ce que je sais
qu'actuellement la y en a pas entre vous
qui sont en cycle d'ailleurs cette année
la sortie des consoles next gen et de
pleins de projets de nouvelles licences
de truc de malade donc bonne chance pour
casser cycle je n'aurais même merde que
vous je me rassure
bonne chance pour que vos parents comme
les excuses les plus dingues du monde
censée justifier vos absences on ma mère
est une p journée donc y'a pas de soucis
du caté pas lent qu'on cherche une
absence à 1 à huy est membre est venue
d' enquête c'est normal c'est parce que
je dois ya une erreur dans leur machin
ils m'ont dit de passer voir secrétariat
de demain donc ce sera rectifiée de
mains ok pour ça il ya 17 jours sans
aller encore plus tard l'uqat une fois
j'en parle d'absence là mais je te
promets seul en course et au hip hop
l'un des neuf c'est relou après juste
avant tu vois le souci c'est que tu
crois que je vais boncourt alors c'est
des erreurs de j'ai pas d'administration
truc comme ça franchement faut que tu me
crois je vais hambourg maman non mais si
si je te fais confiance mais juste pour
ça les voir c'est embêtant quand même de
recevoir des lettres
voilà merci beaucoup et le mec qui fait
son boulot soit fait pour que ça merde
quoi
bref conclut en vacances on verra bien
sûr nous en échec scolaire à cause de
toutes ces nouvelles choses inquiet dit
pas comment ciblage et qui nous place du
fir raquette d'un racket c'est ça hein
on va à la plage bonjour raquette bon
tissu vacances du film erdre on va pas
se le cacher ou dans est d'ailleurs en
vacances on rencontre souvent plaint
mecs qui sont là justement pour
rencontrer plein de filles dans le but
de
2 comment comment veut dire de données
de jeu c'est pas le mec fait quelque
chose vous posez vous avec une fille
juste pas mais c'est plus possible de
faire ça le moment là on vous voit comme
ça nous on vous voit comme ça t la
quatrième de la journée là j'en attends
calvente wade bible par contre faut bien
dire que l'on mon chien quand tu pars en
vacances c'est faire ta valise
d'ailleurs moi aussi ma famille j'étais
encore un peu dans mon monde un monde
dans lequel ma mère n'est absolument pas
syfia toits jardins de riquet ta valise
dans la maison et n'a pas besoin de
saison si tu viens mettre au point son
sac bon c'est quoi ça et ça jo c'est
quoi ça ça c'est au cas où il pleut pas
ce que tu vois c'est ya rien à faire
quand il pleut donc je vous sais c'est
pour s'occuper en attendant c'est tout
mais tu fais pas en train de te fous de
ma gueule
je te promets mais le cam tu vas en
tunisie tunisie pleut jamais là si des
fois ça il ya des gens ils sont encore
plus perdus que moi ok excusez moi oui
ce train là bas il va bien au japon
mais ce n'est pas du tout il va dans le
sud tu l'as amer mais alors c'est par où
la japan expo
jours
bref les vacances c'est détente sur un
transat au soleil au bord de la piscine
ou de la plage et pour ma part ce sera
du 12 au 26 juillet ça va me permettre
de revenir avec plein de nouvelles idées
de prendre un petit peu de recul par
rapport avec youtube de profiter un peu
des vacances et d'être loin d'internet
et tout ça et puis c'est pas pour autant
que je vais vous laisser sans vidéo
en effet pendant ces deux semaines vous
retrouverez chaque mardi et vendredi
soir à 17h sur ma chaîne une nouvelle
vidéo donc soyez à l'heure et coûte que
coûte quoi que vous fassiez ya pas d
excuses
[Musique]
à des dieux en tout cas je vous souhaite
de bonnes vacances à tous et à toutes
vous soyez sur l'enduit sur la plage
profitez bien et amusez vous bien en
skate sur ma nouvelle outre ocha
automobile et à mardi
[Musique]
on va mettre deuxième bougie au juste la
remettre tout léger en place de ce que
j'adore plus kg en remettre une teinte
bleue membres dans ce recueil s'est
ramassé la tête d'agrippa alors à quoi m